And it's amazingly good. You know, I've spent hours playing with this stuff. And where VR, typically I find very isolating and very disorienting, and I get sick really quick with VR. Lots of people do. I could spend all day with Jerry's stuff with Tilt 5, and, you know, it's beautiful. It's not isolating you have glasses on but your your displays are effectively clear and your pico projectors are pointing out welcome to adsp the podcast episode 163, recorded on December 12, 2023.
而且它好得惊人。你知道的，我花了好几个小时玩这东西。通常情况下，我觉得虚拟现实（VR）非常具有隔离感，而且会让人非常晕头转向，我玩 VR 很快就会恶心。很多人都这样。我可以一整天都玩杰瑞（Jerry）的 Tilt 5，而且，你知道的，它很美妙。它不会产生隔离感，你戴着眼镜，但你的显示器实际上是透明的，你的微微投影仪（Pico projectors）正朝外发射。欢迎收听 adsp 播客第 163 期，录制于 2023 年 12 月 12 日。
My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we chat with Sean Parent about the stories behind Jerry Ellsworth of Tilt 5, Greg Gallinos of MetroWorks, Jean-Louis Gasset of Bee Incorporated, and more. Oh, yeah. So the Tilt 5 stuff is actually Jerry's second generation. So I've known Jerry Ellsworth a long time.. She created a Commodore 64, like in a little box that you could connect to your TV. So like, I want to say emulator, but, you know, she was basically re-implemented all the hardware and stuff in this tiny little box and put all these escape hatches. And so this whole kind of hacker community evolved around this little device that she she developed and she had been contracted to do it by by by some company. So she made a name for herself on that. And then she got a job at Steam and she was doing research into VR stuff. And her story is she had on her workbench some Pico projectors for doing VR stuff, which would normally be projecting into your eye. And she had them sitting on her desk, facing away from her while she was trying to fix something on them. And while she was doing that,
我叫康纳（Connor），今天我和我的共同主持布莱斯（Bryce）一起，与肖恩·帕伦特（Sean Parent）聊了聊关于 Tilt 5 的杰瑞·埃尔斯沃思（Jerry Ellsworth）、MetroWorks 的格雷格·加利诺斯（Greg Gallinos）、Bee 公司的让-路易·加塞（Jean-Louis Gassée）等人的幕后故事。哦，对。所以 Tilt 5 实际上是杰瑞的第二代产品。所以我认识杰瑞·埃尔斯沃思很久了。她创造了一个类似 Commodore 64 的东西，装在一个你可以连接到电视的小盒子里面。所以，我想说这是模拟器，但你知道的，她基本上是在这个微型小盒子里重新实现了所有的硬件之类的东西，并留下了各种逃生舱口。因此，在她开发的这个小设备周围，演变出了整个这种黑客社区，而且她是受某家公司委托来做这件事的。所以她凭此名声大噪。然后她在 Steam 找到了工作，并一直在研究 VR 相关的东西。她的故事是，她的工作台上放着几个用于 VR 的微微投影仪，这些投影仪通常是投射到你的眼睛里的。当她试图修理它们时，它们就放在她的桌子上，背对著她。在她这么做的时候，
she happened to have a piece of retroreflective material draped over a chair that she'd just been playing with for a site experiment. And what she got out of the Pico projector was a hologram projected against this piece of retroreflective cloth and and tried to sell this idea to steam or try to pitch it to steam. And she worked at steam and and they didn't want to go for it. And so she ended up leaving the company, but she was able to keep the IP. She believed in this so strongly she was able to talk the CEO of Steam into letting her keep the IP. And so she left with the IP and she did a startup. Boy, now I'm drawing a blank. We can look it up.
她恰好有一块逆反射材料（retroreflective material）搭在椅子上，那是她刚刚为了一个现场实验而玩过的。她从微微投影仪得到的结果是一个全息图，投射在这块逆反射布上，然后她试图把这个想法卖给 Steam 或者向 Steam 推销。她在 Steam 工作，而他们并不想接受。因此她最终离开了公司，但她得以保留了知识产权（IP）。她对这个项目深信不疑，成功说服了 Steam 的首席执行官让她保留知识产权。于是她带着知识产权离开，并创立了一家初创公司。天哪，我现在脑子一片空白。我们可以查一下。
But she did a startup between Steam and doing Tilt 5 where she was using this and she was pitching it for kind of all kinds of purposes. Like, you know, if you were an architect, you could, you know, instead of building physical models, you could bring in your clients and you could do this virtual model and your client could walk around and point to things. And so she tried to make a run at it from this startup and ran out of funding and somehow managed to walk away with the IP again and then started Tilt 5. And Tilt 5 now has gotten to the point where they're a shipping product. And it's amazingly good. You know, I've spent hours playing with this stuff and where VR typically I find very isolating and very disorienting. And I get sick really quick with VR. Lots of people do. I could spend all day with Jerry's stuff with Tilt 5. And, you know, it's not isolating you have glasses on but your
但她在 Steam 和 Tilt 5 之间创立了一家初创公司，当时她一直在使用这个技术，并将其推销用于各种用途。比如，如果你是一名建筑师，你可以，你知道的，不用建造实体模型，而是可以把你的客户带进来，你可以制作这个虚拟模型，你的客户可以四处走动并指出各种东西。因此，她试图通过这家初创公司来进行尝试，结果资金耗尽，不知怎么的又一次成功保留了知识产权脱身，然后创立了 Tilt 5。而 Tilt 5 现在已经发展到了推出量产产品的阶段。而且它好得惊人。你知道的，我花了好几个小时玩这东西，而通常情况下，我觉得 VR 非常具有隔离感，而且会让人非常晕头转向。我玩 VR 很快就会恶心。很多人都这样。我可以一整天都玩杰瑞的 Tilt 5。而且，你知道的，它不会产生隔离感，你戴着眼镜，但你的
your displays are effectively clear and your Pico projectors are pointing out and so your your view of the rest of the world is unobstructed and you got this very crisp display the display that comes back is actually a light field display, which means that the display has natural depth. And so by just changing your eye focus, you can focus on what's close to you or what's far away. Oh, wow. And so it's incredibly impressive. And then she's done a lot of stuff to get visual persistence and high frame rates.
你的显示器实际上是透明的，你的微微投影仪是朝外发射的，所以你对世界其余部分的视野是毫无阻碍的，而且你拥有非常清晰的显示屏。返回的显示屏实际上是一个光场显示屏（light field display），这意味着该显示屏具有自然的深度。因此，只需改变眼睛的焦距，你就可以聚焦于离你近或远的东西。哦，哇。所以这真的令人印象深刻。而且她为了获得视觉持久性和高帧率，做了很多工作。
And so in the stuff that I did for Lightroom Mobile and Lightroom Web and now Photoshop Mobile and Photoshop Web, I frankly stole a bunch of ideas from her to get to get smooth, smooth pan and zoom working in those those products and very high frame rates. She has some really nice software techniques to keep everything locked. So it's interesting, even if your computer freezes, there's enough intelligence in the glasses that you still can move around and see different angles of the scene that's frozen. Huh.
因此，在我为 Lightroom Mobile、Lightroom Web 以及现在的 Photoshop Mobile 和 Photoshop Web 所做的工作中，坦白说，我抄袭了她的一堆想法，以便在这些产品中实现流畅的平移和缩放以及极高的帧率。她有一些非常好的软件技术来保持一切锁定。所以这很有趣，即使你的计算机死机了，眼镜中也有足够的智能，你仍然可以移动并查看冻结场景的不同角度。哈？
Huh? So it's, yeah. So for your listener, I strongly recommend they go out and buy a Tilt 5 system. Yeah. I mean, link will be in the description. Let's check how much it costs. It's much cheaper than a, actually, I don't know how much the, what is it? What do they call it?
哈？所以，是的。因此，对于你的听众，我强烈建议他们去买一个 Tilt 5 系统。是的。我的意思是，链接会放在说明里。让我们看看它要多少钱。它比，实际上，我不知道多少钱，那个叫什么？
Oculus. Do they still call it the same thing? But I know the Apple one is like thousands. Yeah, that's, Tilt 5 did a great ad where they're like, you could buy the Apple system or you could buy a Tilt 5 system for you and all your friends. Yeah. It says here that there's a bundle for like $6.59. I'm guessing this isn't Canadian because my browser should recognize I'm in Canada.
Oculus。他们现在还这么叫吗？但我知道苹果的那款要几千块。对，那是，Tilt 5 做了一个很棒的广告，他们说你可以买苹果的系统，或者你可以买一个 Tilt 5 系统给你和你的所有朋友。对。这里说有一个套装大约 659 美元。我猜这不是加元的，因为我的浏览器应该能识别我在加拿大。
But yeah, I will definitely be looking into this. And two things we couldn't remember the name of. So Technical Illusions, I think, was the first startup, according to her Wikipedia page. And then also Compiler Construction, I believe, was the name of the Nicholas Wirth book. When I Googled Nicholas Wirth Compiler Book, Compiler Construction came up, which says it was initially published in 1996. But yeah, links to all of this stuff will be in the description.
不过是的，我肯定会去了解一下。还有两件我们记不起名字的事情。所以，根据她的维基百科页面，Technical Illusions 应该是第一家初创公司。然后还有《Compiler Construction》（编译器构造），我相信这就是尼克劳斯·维尔特（Nikirth Wirth）那本书的名字。当我用谷歌搜索尼克劳斯·维尔特的编译器书籍时，《Compiler Construction》跳了出来，上面说它最初出版于 1996 年。不过是的，所有这些东西的链接都会在说明中。
First published in 1996. Okay. I found a 96, a 2005, and a 2017, and definitely it wasn't the latter ones. But okay, we'll find the initial publishing name. But this is very cool. And I feel like this guy, you know, Bryce isn't interested, but I feel like this kind of, you know, this combined with like a D&D type of thing, you can still use your imagination. But still, it would be very cool to, and it kind of like removes like a ton of limitations on, you know, or maybe, I don't know, maybe in Bryce's opinion,
首次出版于 1996 年。好的。我找到了 96 年、2005 年和 2017 年的版本，绝对不是后面那些。不过好吧，我们会找到最初出版的名字。但这真的很酷。而且我觉得这家伙，你知道的，布莱斯虽然不感兴趣，但我觉得这种，你知道的，这结合了龙与地下城（D&D）类型的东西，你仍然可以使用你的想象力。但即便如此，这也会非常酷，而且它有点像消除了大量的限制，你知道的，或者也许，我不知道，也许在布莱斯的观点看来，
it constrains you because now you have to design everything. I would try it. I would try it. Bryce is, Bryce is, I was saying I would try it. I would try it. It's, it's, it's very cool in, you know, kind of a group setting. You can get, you know, three or four people with the glasses looking at the same table, and you all see the table from your own perspective. Right. And then you've got the virtualness so that you can have the dungeon master who can see additional information on the table.
它限制了你，因为现在你必须设计所有东西。我会试试的。我会试试的。布莱斯是，布莱斯是，我说过我会试试的。我会试试的。它，它，它在，你知道的，某种群体设置中非常酷。你可以让三四个人戴着眼镜看着同一张桌子，你们所有人都能从各自的角度看到桌子。没错。然后你还有虚拟性，这样你就可以有一个地下城主（dungeon master），他可以看到桌子上的额外信息。
Yeah, yeah yeah yeah can't see um but it's one of those things where where you kind of have to see it before you appreciate it because like you can stand up and walk around the entire table and see all the sides yeah so it's it's the closest thing to um uh you know the star wars holograms that yeah another thing that I I mean this was a like a pipe dream but like I've I've written a Scrabble training program called Hookstar which basically is a combination between Family Feud and Scrabble that every time let's talk about the name let's talk about the name though uh it's It's just a misspelling of my last name. But hooks are a very common term in Scrabble where you build one word by spelling that word, but then hooking off of another word, which like the most common hook, obviously, is an S. You can hook an S to make something plural or to change the tense and then spell another word. But there's a bunch of other way, way less common hooks,
对对对对，你看不到，嗯，但这就是那种你必须亲自看到才能欣赏它的东西，因为你可以站起来绕着整张桌子走，看到所有的面。是的，所以这是最接近，嗯，你知道的，星球大战的全息图的东西。是的，还有一件事，我的意思是，这就像是一个白日梦，但我写了一个名为 Hookstar 的拼字游戏（Scrabble）训练程序，它基本上是家庭问答（Family Feud）和拼字游戏的结合体，每次——让我们谈谈名字吧，还是谈谈名字吧，嗯——它只是我姓氏的一个拼写错误。但 hook 在拼字游戏中是一个非常常见的术语，你通过拼出一个词来构建一个词，但又钩住另一个词，就像最常见的 hook 显然是 S 一样。你可以钩住一个 S 使其变成复数或改变时态，然后再拼出另一个词。但还有一堆其他不太常见的 hook，
like if you are changing the word hat by adding a prefix C to make chat. And then there's a bunch of crazy hooks, like a very common one that all Scrabble pros know about is EAU is a valid Scrabble word that is just the French word for water, but it shows up in English dictionaries, so it's playable. But the plural is also a very common Scrabble word, E-A-U-X. And a lot of people, a lot of Scrabble pros know that, like, beginner Scrabble players don't know that word, so they will specifically put the E-A-U with a triple word or letter score after the E-A-U so that they can get, like, a triple X in two different directions
比如如果你通过添加前缀 C 把单词 hat 改成 chat。然后还有一堆疯狂的 hook，比如所有拼字游戏高手都知道的一个非常常见的词是 EAU，这是一个合法的拼字游戏单词，它只是法语中“水”的意思，但它出现在英语词典中，所以它是可以玩的。但它的复数也是一个非常常见的拼字游戏单词，E-A-U-X。很多人，很多拼字游戏高手都知道，初学者拼字游戏玩家不知道这个词，所以他们会专门把 E-A-U 放在 E-A-U 后面带有三倍单词或字母得分的地方，这样他们就可以在两个不同的方向上获得三倍的 X，
and turn that eight points into, what is eight times six? 48 points for a single letter. Anyways, going on a tangent here. I've always thought it would be cool to play a like holographic Scrabble that shows you these kinds of like word hints and stuff. And then also too, one of the things about Scrabble is you have to spin the board because it's easier to find words if it's facing you. But with a holographic one, just as you mentioned, you can change the perspective.
把那 8 分变成，8 乘以 6 是多少？一个字母 48 分。不管怎样，扯远了。我一直认为玩一个能向你展示这种单词提示之类的全息拼字游戏会很酷。然后还有，关于拼字游戏的一点是，你必须旋转棋盘，因为如果它面向你，更容易找到单词。但有了全息棋盘，正如你所提到的，你可以改变透视角度。
And technically, I think you could have just like each person looking at the board, you know, the correct way. Like it sounds like it would be capable to basically just have a first, you know, player point of view for each person. And then when you're placing, it'll just show like the reflected version
从技术上讲，我认为你可以让每个人都以正确的方式看着棋盘。听起来它基本上能够为每个人提供第一人称视角。然后当你放置时，它只会向另一个人显示反射的版本。
to the other person. And I always thought about building like a hardware version of this, but I was like, that's way too involved. But now it sounds like this wouldn't be too hard to take like a Python 2d application with some knowledge and like translate it into sort of this 3d augmented version,
我一直想构建这个东西的硬件版本，但我当时想，这太复杂了。但现在听起来，要把一个带有某种知识的 Python 2D 应用程序转化并变成这种 3D 增强版本并不是太难，
which would be super cool. They have a really nice SDK too, that, you know, helps with the, you know, so you don't have to become the 3D expert. Right. So, yeah, so definitely check it out.
那会超级酷。他们还有一个非常好的 SDK，你知道的，可以提供帮助，所以你不需要成为 3D 专家。没错。所以，是的，绝对要去看看。
And also any of the systems you purchase are the developer system, so you don't need a separate system to do development on it. And you can just buy the system and download the SDK and reach and this is gonna this is the this guy's unlimited now i'm thinking if i can just carry like it's even better than carrying a scrabble board around because those things are pretty hefty all you need is these two glasses and some power source or i'm sure there's batteries on it you could take this on a plane and then you know sitting next to your friend just both be sitting forward and then play a board game virtually yeah all right that would be pretty cool that'd be pretty cool you do need the little you do need
而且你购买的任何系统都是开发者系统，所以你不需要单独的系统来进行开发。你只需购买系统并下载 SDK 即可。这太棒了，这家伙现在势不可挡。我在想，如果我能随身携带，这甚至比随身携带一个拼字游戏棋盘还要好，因为那些东西相当笨重。你只需要这两副眼镜和一些电源，或者我确信上面有电池，你可以把它带上飞机，然后，你知道的，坐在你的朋友旁边，两人都朝前坐着，然后虚拟地玩棋盘游戏。是的，好吧，那会很酷。那会相当酷。你确实需要那个，你确实需要
the retroreflective mat so you're going to need like uh you know talk to jerry about making like airplane tray sized man yeah yeah so so you can do that that's i have no idea how we went on this hard hard left or right tangent we were talking about hardware. You know, hardware and how is it easier or harder for somebody to get started in hardware these days than it was when Nicholas Virich was building a Lilith machine. And I think it's a little bit of both, right? There are some things that are easier and some things that are harder. And Jerry's my example of uh you know the amazing things a small company can do wow do you know if is i guess this uh ip is patented
逆反射垫，所以你需要像，你知道的，跟杰瑞谈谈做个飞机托盘大小的垫子。是的，是的，所以你可以做到这一点，我不知道我们是怎么拐到这个极其左倾或右倾的题外话上的。我们当时在谈论硬件。你知道，硬件，对于某人来说，现在涉足硬件比尼克劳斯·维尔特（Nicholas Virich）制造莉莉丝机器（Lilith machine）时更容易还是更难？我认为两者兼而有之，对吧？有些事情更容易，有些事情更难。杰瑞就是我的例子，说明一个小公司能做出惊人的事情。哇，你知道这，我猜这个知识产权是由 Tilt 5 申请了专利吗？
i'm i guess by tilt 5 so there's no chance of uh like microsoft hololens uh like stealing this and uh you know yeah not till the patents expire so whenever that lasts interesting i had no idea about this definitely check it out it's uh it's pretty cool yeah where do we i mean where so if i if we skip all the way back to uh i'm trying to find where's the tab i've got like 40 tabs open now with the uh the you know wikipedia profile of jerry ellsworth and all the the different things the links will all be in the show notes um i'm trying to think if you know you mentioned metroWorks and that you had written some projects in Modula 2. And then I think, yeah,
我猜是 Tilt 5 拥有的，所以微软全息眼镜（Hololens）之类的东西绝对没有机会窃取这个，然后，你知道的，是的，直到专利过期为止。所以无论什么时候过期。有趣，我对这个一无所知。一定要去看看，它，它挺酷的。是的，我们在哪里——我的意思是，我们在哪里——如果我一直回溯到，嗯，我正试图找到标签页在哪里，我现在打开了大约 40 个标签页，里面有杰瑞·埃尔斯沃思的维基百科资料以及各种不同的东西，链接都会在节目笔记中——我在想，你知道的，你提到了 MetroWorks，并且你用 Modula 2 编写了一些项目。然后我想，是的，
you posted something earlier about, I guess we sort of covered that, yeah. C++ was used to replace Object Pascal. So I guess, yeah, like to wrap things up, because I know this is kind of like the time we were aiming to end at, you know, is there anything more to say about the, because I have absolutely, you know,
你之前发布了一些东西，关于，我猜我们基本上讨论过了，是的。C++ 被用来替代 Object Pascal。所以我想，是的，为了作个总结，因为我知道这差不多是我们设定的结束时间，你知道的，关于这个还有什么好说的吗？因为我绝对，你知道的，
no idea what the MetroWorks CodeWarrior IDE was, or, you know, you mentioned the Modulate 2 projects, or any of those things worth mentioning? Like you linked to the Lilith computer, so we'll definitely throw that in the show notes if folks want to read more about it. Was there anything special about those IDEs? So CodeWarrior, I kind of view as the
完全不知道 MetroWorks CodeWarrior IDE 是什么，或者，你知道的，你提到了 Modula 2 项目，或者这些事情中有哪件是值得一提的？就像你链接到了莉莉丝计算机（Lilith computer），所以如果大家想了解更多信息，我们一定会把它放进节目笔记里。这些 IDE 有什么特别之处吗？所以 CodeWarrior，我有点把它视为
precursor to every modern IDE. I mean, it was really, even though it... When did it come out? I don't know offhand. So it would have been maybe 93 or 94, right in there. Could be 92. Wikipedia says December 23rd, 1993. So you're exactly correct. Yeah. So Greg Gallinose just on his own wrote a Modula 2 compiler and he was selling it to a handful of Mac people, myself included. And so, you know, when I got stuck in Modula 2, I would pick up the phone and call their tech support and it would be Greg Gallinose. Rest in peace, Greg. Greg passed away here recently. And then when Apple switched to PowerPC, that left this compiler gap in the space. And Apple's compiler at the time was pretty horrible. Most people were using, I think it was called Lightspeed C at the time for actually doing Mac development, but they had a 68K backend and no
每个现代 IDE 的前身。我的意思是，真的，尽管它……它是什么时候出来的？我随口说不上来。所以它可能在 93 或 94 年左右，就在那个时候。也可能是 92 年。维基百科说的是 1993 年 12 月 23 日。所以你完全正确。是的。所以格雷格·加利诺斯（Greg Gallinos）单枪匹马编写了一个 Modula 2 编译器，并把它卖给了一小批 Mac 用户，包括我自己在内。所以，你知道的，当我卡在 Modula 2 时，我会拿起电话打给他们的技术支持，接听的就会是格雷格·加利诺斯。愿格雷格安息。格雷格最近在这里去世了。然后当苹果转向 PowerPC 时，这就留下了这个编译器领域的空白。当时苹果的编译器相当糟糕。大多数人都在使用，我记得当时叫 Lightspeed C 来进行实际的 Mac 开发，但它们有一个 68K 后端却没有
PowerPC backend. IBM had a good compiler, but you needed a power workstation to actually run it. So that wasn't very approachable. And so Greg Gallinos decided, hey, I know all the compiler people in the industry. I could go build a virtual company if I don't ask these people to all move to one location. If I just call them up and say, hey, let's build an IDE and build a compiler, we can do it. So they created the, you know, MentorWorks Code Warrior was their IDE, and they had a C++ compiler. And almost all of the PowerPC projects on the Mac at the time were built on top of it. And it was, you know, an incredibly successful project. And, you know,
PowerPC 后端。IBM 有一个很好的编译器，但你需要一台工作站级别的电脑来实际运行它。所以这并不是很平易近人。因此格雷格·加利诺斯决定，嘿，我认识行业里所有的编译器人员。如果我不要求这些人全部搬到一个地方，我可以建立一家虚拟公司。如果我只是打电话给他们说，嘿，让我们建立一个 IDE 并构建一个编译器，我们可以做到。于是他们创建了，你知道的，MentorWorks Code Warrior 是他们的 IDE，他们有一个 C++ 编译器。当时 Mac 上的几乎所有 PowerPC 项目都是基于它构建的。而且它是一个，你知道的，非常成功的项目。而且，你知道的，
at one point, they purchased some technology, which was called Latitude, which was because they were trying to branch out onto Windows. And so they shipped their compiler for a while on Windows. They purchased some technology called Latitude, which lets you run Mac software to a limited degree on Windows. if I mentioned in one of our previous talks, but at one point after Steve Jobs came over, retook over Apple, and there was this gap where Apple was pushing Rhapsody and no company was looking to support Rhapsody. I cooked up this idea with Eric Trout, who Eric Trout had done the dynamic recompiling emulator for 68K code to run on power pc at apple and then he did a virtual pc at connectix and some other products at connectix a virtual playstation at connectix so you could you could emulate a playstation 1 on your mac he and i had this idea of if Apple isn't going to support traditional Mac anymore,
在某个时候，他们收购了一些名为 Latitude 的技术，这是因为他们正试图拓展到 Windows 领域。所以他们在 Windows 上发布了一段时间的编译器。他们收购了一些名为 Latitude 的技术，这能让你在一定程度上在 Windows 上运行 Mac 软件。如果我在我们之前的某次谈话中提到过，但在史蒂夫·乔布斯回来、重新接管苹果之后的一段时间里，出现了一个真空期，当时苹果在大力推行 Rhapsody，而没有公司希望支持 Rhapsody。我和埃里克·特劳特（Eric Trout）一起想出了这个主意，埃里克·特劳特曾在苹果公司制作过用于在 PowerPC 上运行 68K 代码的动态重编译模拟器，后来他在 Connectix 制作了虚拟机（Virtual PC），在 Connectix 制作了其他一些产品，在 Connectix 制作了虚拟 PlayStation（Virtual PlayStation），这样你就可以在 Mac 上模拟 PlayStation 1。他和我有这样一个想法：如果苹果不再支持传统的 Mac，
why don't we talk to the guys at Bee? And we think we know enough people in the industry, and we could get together a plan to build a Mac competitor. And so we talked to our engineer friends and invited them to a meeting. And somehow we ended up in a meeting with Jean-Louis Gosset, who was the CEO of Bee. For people who don't know, Bee made their own computers based off a 603 PowerPC chip running their own OS called BOS at the time. Jean-Louis Gosset had come out of Apple. And so they were building this machine. And Apple had started licensing macOS. And so there were a lot of people
为什么不跟 Bee 的那些人谈谈呢？我们认为我们对业内的人足够了解，我们可以制定一个计划来建立一个 Mac 的竞争对手。于是我们跟我们的工程师朋友们聊了聊，邀请他们开个会。不知怎么的，我们最终跟 Bee 的首席执行官让-路易·加塞（Jean-Louis Gassée）开会。对于那些不知道的人来说，Bee 当时制造了自己的计算机，基于 603 PowerPC 芯片，运行他们自己的操作系统，当时叫 BOS。让-路易·加塞是从苹果出来的。所以他们当时在制造这台机器。而苹果已经开始授权 macOS。所以当时有很多人
who were going to build Mac clones, including IBM, who at the time IBM built ThinkPads and IBM was going to build a PowerPC ThinkPad running macOS. And then Steve Jobs came back and squashed all the clones of those ideas. Smart. And so IBM was very far along that pipe. So we end up in this meeting with a bunch of CEOs and executives at various companies to pitch this idea.
打算制造 Mac 克隆机，包括 IBM，当时的 IBM 制造 ThinkPad，并且 IBM 打算制造一台运行 macOS 的 PowerPC ThinkPad。然后史蒂夫·乔布斯回来了，把所有这些克隆想法全部扼杀在摇篮里。明智。所以 IBM 当时在那个方向上已经进展得很远了。于是我们跟各家公司的许多首席执行官和高管开会，来推销这个想法。
And basically our idea was, look, we can take the Connectix has something that they called Speed Doubler, which was a very fast dynamic recompiling emulator for 68K. Because at the time to run Mac, you still needed to emulate some amount of 68K, even on PowerPC. So we've got the emulator. We've got Greg Galanos here, and he owns Compatibility Shim for macOS, which actually just implements a whole bunch of macOS from the ground up. We've got the B operating system, and we've got Jean-Louis Gasset, and the thinking was, and then we have hardware manufacturers who are sitting waiting to ship PowerPC Macs, and we said, well, instead of shipping PowerPC Macs, how about we build Mac clones and sitting on top of the B operating
基本上我们的想法是，听着，我们可以把 Connectix 拥有的一个叫 Speed Doubler 的东西拿过来，这是一个针对 68K 的非常快速的动态重编译模拟器。因为当时要运行 Mac，你仍然需要模拟一定数量的 68K，即使是在 PowerPC 上。所以我们有了模拟器。我们这里有格雷格·加利诺斯，他拥有 macOS 的兼容性垫片（Compatibility Shim），实际上是从头开始实现了整个 macOS 的一大堆功能。我们有了 B 操作系统，我们有了让-路易·加塞，当时的想法是，然后我们有硬件制造商正坐在那里等待发货 PowerPC Mac，我们说，好吧，与其发货 PowerPC Mac，不如我们基于 B 操作系统构建 Mac 克隆机，
system and let you run Mac software and ship this new hardware. So I was involved with Greg in that. It ultimately fell apart largely because everybody said, well, we need high profile apps to ship on this thing. And I went to John Warnock and John said no, that he, although he didn't believe in what Steve was doing with Rhapsody, he was not going to, you know, undermineve and take him on head to head with a mac compatible clone and so so without a high profile app that was committed to this uh uh hybrid machine that effort kind of fell apart and and it was very complicated anyways we had you know so many companies and people involved and all with their own take and and, you know, who was going to license what to who and his Windows business to Nokia. And he sold that off.
并让你运行 Mac 软件并推出这个新硬件。所以我跟格雷格一起参与了那件事。它最终破裂了，很大程度上是因为每个人都说，好吧，我们需要高级别的应用程序在这个东西上发布。我去找了约翰·沃诺克（John Warnock），约翰说不，尽管他不赞同史蒂夫对 Rhapsody 的做法，但他不会，你知道的，去破坏并与 Mac 兼容克隆机正面交锋。所以，没有一个致力于这个，嗯，嗯，混合机器的高级别应用程序，那项努力就有点破裂了。而且无论如何它非常复杂，我们有，你知道的，那么多的公司和人参与进来，每个人都有自己的看法，还有，谁将把什么授权给谁……并将他的 Windows 业务卖给诺基亚。他把它卖掉了。
And then like two weeks later, Apple announced that Apple was moving from PowerPC to Intel. They gave him no heads up. And that basically killed MetroWorks and CodeWarrior. I was at the Apple's WWDC, you knowDC with Greg when that was announced. And we were kind of in a back room. And yeah, he was in tears. It was like the end of his company in one fell swoop. He went on, just not like he was doing poorly.
然后大概两周后，苹果宣布苹果将从 PowerPC 转向英特尔。他们没有给他任何提前通知。这基本上杀死了 MetroWorks 和 CodeWarrior。当这个消息宣布时，我和格雷格一起在苹果的 WWDC 上。我们当时在一个小房间里。是的，他泪流满面。这就像是一场空，他的公司在一夜之间走到了尽头。他继续前进，并不是说他过得不好。
He went on to be a venture capitalist for SoftBank for the rest of his career. But I guess it's less about whether you're doing well or not. It's, you know, if you built a thing and you want to see it succeed. Exactly. You know, a horrible thing, and it comes about, you know, I always think
他的职业生涯的余下时间里一直在为软银（SoftBank）担任风险投资家。但我想这与其说关乎你过得好不好，不如说，你知道的，如果你构建了一件东西，并且你希望看到它成功。完全正确。你知道的，一件糟糕的事情发生了，你知道的，我总是觉得
Apple is just way too closed and doesn't communicate well with their developers. And that's one historical example of if they had been communicating with their number one tool vendor in advance, then he would have been ready day one with an Intel compiler. But Apple was building their own Xcode compiler and wasn't talking and blindsided him. Just like on Survivor. You've been voted off the island.
苹果实在是太封闭了，与开发者的沟通做得很不好。这是一个历史性的例子，如果他们提前与他们最重要的工具供应商进行沟通，那么他就会在第一天就准备好英特尔编译器。但苹果当时在构建他们自己的 Xcode 编译器，却闭口不谈，打了他个措手不及。就像在《幸存者》（Survivor）节目里一样。你已经被投票出局了。
Yeah. So that's my MetroWorks story. That's a pretty good one, I've got to say. Greg was a super nice guy. I mean, I still work. Eric Scouten at Adobe was one of the MetroWorks compiler guys, and he's now doing the content authenticity work that I mentioned earlier. So, kind of small world well probably we've kept you for an hour and a half now and uh yeah we gotta let you we usually do yeah this i know i mean i mean i feel like i think this is the second time we i looked i i looked back when we had interviewed we i think we did two or
是的。这就是我的 MetroWorks 故事。我必须说，这是一个相当不错的故事。格雷格是一个超级好的人。我的意思是，我还在工作。Adobe 的埃里克·斯考滕（Eric Scouten）是 MetroWorks 的编译器人员之一，他现在正在从事我之前提到过的内容真实性（content authenticity）工作。所以，世界真小。好吧，可能我们已经留你一个半小时了，嗯，是的，我们得放你走了，我们通常都会这样。是的，我知道，我的意思是，我感觉这是我们第二次，我看了看，我回顾了一下我们采访过的时候，我想我们在 2021 年做过两
three times in 2021 and then we did zero times in 2022. You know, we upset our listeners to no end. And you, as we would mention every other episode, oh, we'll have Sean on and we'll reach out to him at some point. And we never did. And then this is the second time in 2023. So we will make sure, we promise the listener, we will not go through 2024 without at least once,
三次，然后在 2022 年零次。你知道的，我们把听众气得要死。而你，正如我们在每隔一期节目中都会提到的，哦，我们会请肖恩来，我们会在某个时候联系他。但我们从来没有这样做过。而这是 2023 年的第二次。所以我们一定会向听众保证，我们向听众承诺，2024 年绝对不会至少一次都不找你，
but probably multiple times. I mean, hopefully, I'm not sure what conferences if you've said, when are we going to see you next? What are your? I don't know, right? I have no conference commitments right now. I've got an invite to a user group meeting. What is it Northwest user group meeting up in Well, hey, I hear that there's a bunch of Adobe C++ people in New York now and we have a meetup in New York
不过很可能会是多次。我的意思是，希望如此，我不太确定是什么会议，如果你说过，我们什么时候能再见到你？你的……我不知道，对吧？我现在没有任何会议承诺。我收到了一个用户组会议的邀请。是什么？西北用户组会议，在……好吧，嘿，我听说现在纽约有一堆 Adobe 的 C++ 人员，我们在纽约有一个聚会，
you can come here and visit us and kind of visit me Who are all the David didn't move down to, I guess he's got a big family David Sankel's here and then recently Cool, well let me know when you're I guess, yeah, he's got a big family. David Sankel's here. And then recently... Cool.
你可以来这里参观我们，顺便拜访我……大卫没搬到……我猜他有一个大家庭。大卫·桑克尔（David Sankel）在这里，然后最近……酷，好吧，当你在……我猜，是的，他有一个大家庭。大卫·桑克尔在这里。然后最近……酷。
Well, let me know when you're heading to town. I will take you to get good food. Sometime in the spring, I will be in the Seattle area giving a talk at the Northwest meetup. I've got to figure out dates for that. And Adobe has an office in the Seattle area, so I want to spend some time there. We didn't talk at all. Dave Abrahams and I gave a talk at CppCon on contracts. We can talk about that next time. Yeah. How do you think C++ contracts are going? How do I think C++ contracts are going? I don't know. Me neither. Yeah. I don't know me neither I don't think they're completely off the rails
好吧，当你打算来这里时告诉我。我会带你去吃好吃的。在春天的某个时候，我将在西雅图地区发表演讲，在西北聚会上。我得弄清楚那里的日期。Adobe 在西雅图地区有一个办公室，所以我想在那里呆一段时间。我们根本没聊这个。戴夫·亚伯拉罕（Dave Abrahams）和我曾在 CppCon 上就契约（contracts）发表过演讲。我们下次可以聊聊这个。是的。你对 C++ 契约有什么看法？我对我对 C++ 契约有什么看法？我不知道。我也一样。是的。我不知道，我也是。我不认为它们完全脱轨了，
but they're also not quite what I want yet some of what I want they will support I'm just more opinionated I would enforce as opposed to support and then some of what I want they don't support yet so we can talk about contracts next time. Cue that up. We will definitely cue that up.
但它们也还不是我想要的。它们将支持我想要的一部分，我只是更有主见，我会倾向于强制执行而不是支持，而我想要的一部分它们还不支持，所以我们下次可以谈谈契约。做好准备。我们一定会做好准备。
And I mean, depending on how schedules work out, but I assume, so does the New York C++ meetup, do they have a set location or does it hop around to whoever's hosting? Sometimes it's at Adobe. So that's what I was going to say. I'm going to guess that it's going to be held at Adobe.
我的意思是，这取决于日程安排如何，但我假设，那么纽约的 C++ 聚会有固定的地点吗，还是说会在任何主办方那里到处跑？有时是在 Adobe。所以这就是我要说的。我猜它会在 Adobe 举行。
So maybe I'm assuming Bryce, pending he's in New York at the time, will be attending. Yeah, which is not at all a given. Yeah. So if Bryce is going to be there, maybe I'll, depending on what my schedule is, I'll hop down because Toronto's like...
所以我假设布莱斯，如果他届时在纽约的话，会出席。是的，这根本不是板上钉钉的事。是的。所以如果布莱斯要去的话，也许我会，这取决于我的日程安排，我会顺便过去，因为多伦多就像是……
Well, even if I'm not going to be there, because you can always just stay at my apartment. Oh, yeah, that's true. But I mean, it would be cool if you were there. Yeah, it would be cool there and then we came down and then we could do like uh you know we didn't we wouldn't have to record for a whole extra hour and a half down there but we could do like a little mini thing if i'm assuming there'd be some kind of social afterwards and uh presumably yeah yeah i mean usually some folks go out for
好吧，即使我不去，因为你也可以一直住在我的公寓里。哦，对，那倒是真的。但我的意思是，如果你能在那里那就太酷了。是的，在那里会很酷，然后我们过去，然后我们可以做个类似，你知道的，我们在那里不需要额外录制一个半小时，但如果我们能做一个小小的活动，假设之后会有某种社交活动的话，想必是的。是的，我的意思是，通常有些人会去
for um uh for drinks at some bar afterwards um It depends on who's there. And also I suppose the, the weather. There you go. You can, we can do a drunk podcasting again, like at. Yes.
喝一杯，去某个酒吧喝一杯……这取决于谁在那里。我也假设，还有天气。你看。你可以，我们可以再次做一次微醺播客，就像在……是的。
Yes. That was fun. That was fun. CPP on C. Yeah. Yeah. Yes. Yeah.
是的。那很有趣。那很有趣。CPP on C。是的。是的。是的。是的。
That was, you know, like I've said it on multiple times. It's gotta be one of the high. Oh yeah. Our get ready. Bryce,, that was, you know, like I've said it on multiple times. It's got to be one of the high. Oh, yeah, our Get Ready, Bryce, our new year, you know, reflecting on 2023, looking ahead forward to 2024, which was one of my favorite episodes is when you came up with the Star Wars analogy. Definitely in my top five will be the C++ on C recording. I guess I got to start thinking about what my top five is.
你知道的，就像我多次说过的那样。这绝对是高潮之一。哦，是的。我们的“准备好，布莱斯”，那是，你知道的，就像我多次说过的那样。这绝对是高潮之一。哦，是的，我们的“准备好，布莱斯”，我们的新年，你知道的，回顾 2023 年，展望 2024 年，这是我最喜欢的集数之一，就是你提出了《星球大战》类比的时候。绝对在我的前五名中，那就是 C++ on C 的录音。我想我得开始想想我的前五名是什么了。
I mean, obviously, there's the road trip. That was pretty good. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. It's going to be hard to match that. It's going to be hard to beat that, yeah. I think Dave Abrahams might be at C++ on C this year. Okay. I don't know if they're open for submissions yet.
我的意思是，显然，还有那次公路旅行。那挺不错的。哦，是的，是的，是的。要超越那个将是很困难的。要打破那个纪录将是很困难的，是的。我想戴夫·亚伯拉罕今年可能会去 C++ on C。好的。我不知道他们是否已经开放投稿了。
I don't think so because I think Phil listens now and again to these and if he is he'll probably be nodding his head or not nodding his head. We're so lazy. We can't even send an email to somebody. It's just like, hey we'll put this message out there on the podcast.
我想还没有，因为我认为菲尔（Phil）现在偶尔会听这些，如果他在听的话，他可能会点头或者不点头。我们太懒了。我们甚至不能给某人发封电子邮件。就好像，嘿，我们会在播客上把这个消息发出去。
He'll listen and then they'll contact us. I monitor the CF the cfps and uh i know right now that it's not open for c++ on c because there is at least one and i think i saw a headline that said there's two other conferences that phil is running um in in along with c++ on c and the first one is a virtual one that's happening i think in early 2024 like in february so i think most of his attention right now is focused on running that virtual conference.
他会听的，然后他们会联系我们。我关注 CFP，我目前知道 C++ on C 还没有开放，因为至少有一个，而且我好像看到了一条新闻标题说菲尔还在运营另外两个会议，除了 C++ on C 之外，第一个是虚拟会议，我想是在 2024 年初，比如 2 月份举行。所以我认为他目前的大部分注意力都集中在运营那个虚拟会议上。
That's cool. I think the CFP has opened and closed for that one. That's an online C++ conference. I think it's just called C++ Online or something like that. Anyways, notes will be in the, link will be in the show notes. And yeah, hopefully, if not in February or March at some other conference later in 2024, we'll all be able to meet up again.
那挺酷的。我想那个会议的 CFP 已经开放又关闭了。那是一个在线 C++ 会议。我想它就叫 C++ Online 之类的。不管怎样，链接会放在，链接会出现在节目笔记中。是的，希望如果不是在 2 月或 3 月，而是在 2024 年晚些时候的其他会议上，我们都能再次聚在一起。
That would be fun. And yeah, thanks for taking your time to chat with us once again. Obviously, the listeners are thrilled. You're probably half the reason why our podcast has taken off. That's definitely true. Your stories are, you know,
那会很有趣。是的，谢谢你花时间再次与我们聊天。显然，听众们都很激动。你可能占了我们播客腾飞的一半原因。绝对是这样。你的故事，你知道的，
they stand far and tall above all the other ones. You know, at some point I'm going to run out of old stories. I have a hard time believing that because, you know, it's just going to take us migrating to a different topic to jog your memory of to be shouting at the podcast. Why aren't they mentioning this? And then poof, then we'll have a whole new set. And if not, we're just going to have to meet up in person and you know have drinks and just just chat and you know i still think those are wildly entertaining to the listeners so we haven't even gone through all of the stories that i have that i have heard of sean's in my few years of knowing him i i feel
它们远远高大过所有其他的。你知道的，在某个时候我会用完旧故事的。我很难相信这一点，因为，你知道的，这只需要我们迁移到一个不同的主题来唤醒你的记忆，让你在播客里大喊：“为什么他们没提到这个？”然后，嘭，我们就又会有一套全新的内容。如果没有，我们只能亲自见面，你知道的，喝一杯，然后只是聊天，你知道的，我仍然认为这些对听众来说极其有趣，我们甚至还没有讲完我在认识肖恩的几年里听过的所有肖恩的故事。我感觉
like we're gonna be i feel like we'll have plenty, plenty of content for the anticipated lifespan of this podcast. Well, the lifespan is, you know, I thought you said forever. Okay, fair point. Until one of us murders each other. Maybe I was just making a commentary on how long I think it'll take for us to get there. What's the latest on Better Code, the future book? I've got an entire team making as fast as progress
我们会有，我感觉对于这个播客预期的寿命来说，我们会拥有足够多的内容。好吧，寿命是，你知道的，我以为你说的是永远。好吧，有道理。直到我们互相谋杀对方。也许我只是在评论我们认为走到那一步需要多长时间。关于《Better Code》未来这本书有什么最新进展？我有一整个团队在以和我之前写书时一样快的速度取得进展。
as I was making on the book before. That's a very interesting statement. You know, that could be interpreted as a good thing, but if you know how the progress was, the speed of the progress before. Yeah. So, yes, progress is not going as rapidly as I would like.
这是一个非常有趣的说法。你知道的，这可以被解释为一件好事，但如果你知道之前的进展情况的话，进展的速度。是的。所以，是的，进展没有我希望的那么快。
But we are kind of doubling down, at least on our commitments for this next year. Well, that's good. We will see. We have not abandoned the effort. I think increasingly we all believe in the effort. All right. Cool. Well, on that note believe in the effort. So, all right. Cool. Well, on that note, until next time, thanks for coming on.
但我们至少在明年的承诺上加倍努力了。好吧，那很好。我们走着瞧。我们并没有放弃这项努力。我认为越来越多的人对这项努力深信不疑。好吧。酷。好吧，就此而言，深信不疑。所以，好吧。酷。好吧，就此而言，直到下次，谢谢你来做客。
And we will chat in the future, probably next year. Be sure to check the show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSB the podcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a happy new year. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast.
我们以后再聊，可能明年吧。请务必查看你的播客应用中的节目笔记，或者访问 ADSB the podcast.com，获取我们在今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，并祝新年快乐。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。
It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这不是标语。我们的标语是“带有信息点缀的混乱”。这一集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。